he's been covering boston sports for
forever and a day he's got a new book
out um on the uh the car the old uh days
of the larry bird celtics called wish it
lasted forever life with the larry bird
celtics dan shaughnessy here on the rich
eisen show how are you dan i'm good rich
how you doing i'm doing fine congrats on
the book congrats on the book i
appreciate that good times and tell
susie hello for me yeah i know she's
wanted me to say hello to you too why
why write the book dan what's up good
question i mean again this isn't to we
all know who won those games and the
stats and hall of famers but this was a
time when the nba kind of came of age
and we had this amazing access this
jumped out at me during the pandemic
when their you know access got to zero
the moat just kept getting wider wider
and then with abundance of caution
there's no access now but we live with
these guys this is like you know when
the dinosaurs and larry bird myself roam
the earth
we travel with them they flew commercial
hotels lobbies bars
go to practice no close practices be on
the bus it was like except for not
having the groupies or the money the
fame was like being on the team rich i
mean we were like we were there for
everything and um
you know watching the last dance and
some of the classics they showed in the
without games going on during the
pandemic i kept seeing my my young self
sitting there with the giant michael
kane glasses and the big hair and you
know again that's when the lowly media
got to sit next to the bench they hadn't
figured out how to monetize those seats
yet so we were part of that and of
course you had the bird magic you know
take over the 80s and the bird magic
celtic laker finals were like the ali
frazier of that time and i just had all
these stories about being around these
guys and ability to tell the readers
what they were like how secure they were
in their greatness and what a special
time it was when the nba really came of
age so you're saying at some point in
logan airport a boston fan flying to
cleveland uh for just a business trip
got to actually see robert parish board
of flight is that what you're saying
absolutely when we would get off the
plane they were all in first class
because they're so tall and they had
those perks but we'd come off the plane
beyond behind them and you'd see these
people just walking
down the you know
down the airport hallways and they'd be
like oh my god i just saw all these tall
guys at one time those must be a
basketball team and then the lowly
writers would be trailing them and we'd
hear all the whispering about larry bird
or robert parish or whatnot but yeah it
was we waited for bags we did you know
all the rich when when when the coveted
bubble when they had that tournament
with no fans and and
in orlando you had to if you went to
cover that it cost sixty thousand
dollars you had a quarantine for two
weeks and sign a waiver saying you would
not talk to any athlete if you saw them
anywhere and uh that's where we did all
of our work was waiting for bags in the
hotel bars the lobbies being on the bus
we were really able to tell the readers
what these guys were like and it was a
very
special group that they had there the
lakers had it going in that decade as
well and the league really took off
because of that dan shawn is here on the
rich eisen show uh it's interesting that
you you have such a
uh a a i guess a positive view of it and
it's sort of a very uh uh what high
geographic view of it all um me being
from new york i i don't mean enough to
stomp on your book but i have written my
own book and if you want to we actually
have a cover maybe you'll see it later
on uh it it's entitled thank god it
ended
living through the bird celtics in new
york and uh and there's a shot on the
cover of bird shooting over ewing in the
garden um so i have a different view
well it's so funny the 84 yo hubie brown
i just saw him last week you know he's
147 years old like myself and he's still
doing the games and he's so sharp and
great i love him i gave him a copy of
the book but the highlight of his
professional life was that 84 series of
bernard king and they took him seven
games i mean bernard was averaging 40 a
game i remember cedric maxwell called me
over during practice before the first
game of that series because bernard was
getting 40 a game against the pistons in
the playoffs and and max said there's no
way a [ __ ] walks like this is going to
get 40 off of me and then he did a mimic
of bernard's you know unusual gate and
i'm like these guys they were trash
talkers and they didn't care you know
bernard wouldn't shake his hand for the
next game max said hey if you're scared
get a dog he didn't care he was just
that's how they were and that series
went great and again for huby they
almost beat the celtics in game seven at
the garden yeah i just i remember those
knicks um you know piston series with
kelly trapuca yeah right now honestly in
the old joe lewis arena
i remember those as a kid and then
bernard was my favorite player it still
is jarring to see julius randle wearing
his number 30 to be very honest with you
right that's not right you know well i
mean hey look i i mean i guess you know
julius randle at least is is is doing
well by that number as far as i'm
concerned but uh you know just
is there any story that just uh that you
forgot about that you found notes oh
yeah i had a little note so again larry
bird he he could hold all these things
in his head during the game so he'd have
a shooting drill at the old boston
garden you know late in the afternoon by
himself dark garden come out with an
equipment guy and just do the perimeter
shoot for half hour all you heard was
swishing i'd get there early plug in my
stoneage computer right next to the
bench hit come over he called me scuba
says scoop what are you working on i'm
sorry i'm doing an early story you were
approximating the nba record for
consecutive free throws calvin murphy 88
so don't miss one tonight or i'll look
bad in the paper so during the first
half he got fouled he's at the line he
makes the first he looks over and winks
at me before he makes the second i mean
guys don't do that today and he would
actually you know mike saunders the
trainer of the knicks sure
larry was banking threes in madison
square garden before a game because he
was getting bored he won the three-point
thing three years in a row and started
banking him and saunders said you can't
do that in the game and larry said if
you give me five bucks i will and sure
enough they get way ahead of the knicks
fourth quarter he banks the three runs
by the nick bench with his greedy palm
extended and uh where's my five bucks
mike
love stories like that absolutely love
stories like that because his he was the
legend that's that's part of the legend
of larry legend you know and that's
right and the legend so he was so dense
all he cared about was basketball you
know his you know poor guy rural
southern indiana and worked his butt off
became great we were at the atrium in
dallas to play the mavericks and we're
in the hotel bar it's a day off and
springsteen is playing next door at the
reunion arena and the doors flew open
and kids came rushing through the lobby
to get to the concert and larry looks up
he goes what's that all about i said
well bruce springsteen is playing next
door tonight he said who's that
and did i said larry he's the you of
rock and roll he goes oh he must be
pretty good then
you know so you know he got tickets he
went he said yeah yeah it's too loud for
me i don't like that music but he sweats
a lot and i appreciate that work ethic
that's the legend there's no doubt about
that so did he really know where the
spots on the floor were like the dead
spots on the floor
i mean the bull gang you know when you
have the ice in the park k you're going
back and forth and they assemble it and
it cheers the whole episode on the bolts
and all that stuff so he no one really
knew it changed from game to game and if
he
when they would resemble the rims when
he was doing that shooting drill in the
afternoon anytime he missed one he'd say
oh bull gang screwed that up there's
something wrong with the basket it's off
by a quarter an inch otherwise that
would have been nothing but net so you
know he had the thing down but
that's a myth that anyone actually knew
when the ball was going to come back to
you yeah i know again all of these
things ariah wrote my book thank god it
ended you know because
it just honestly just michael and
parrish i despised ml carr growing up
because he just waved a towel
oh my gosh he did nothing he did nothing
but wave a towel that's all i thought he
did mel carr he was a he was a
a guard in a federal prison before
governor of the nba he played in israel
he played overseas played for the st
louis spirits asked
about that and he was larry bird's
bodyguard for the first five years of
larry's career he had very little skill
that at the end but he got in the heads
of the lakers in the greatest final ever
in 84 he would pound on their door
before the game say come out here you la
fakers come out and take you beating
like men come on out here tragic johnson
i mean they didn't care and then at the
end of the game he'd steal the ball and
go dunk on him and just make him even
more furious
you're loving these stories brockman i
know you're i mean i cannot wait for
this i say it's it's all great what's
our box role in all of this well you
know red red was he was just smart when
you know the whole chess when others are
playing checkers he assembled these
teams go back and look at those rosters
in 84 when the celtics beat you know
worthy magic kareem those guys were all
blue chip confident ucla north carolina
michigan state the celtics starting five
went to virginia commonwealth north
carolina charlotte indiana state
centenary and pepperdine so red would
say you know easy to get blue chip and
win like that let's see you do what i do
win with guys from second tier
conferences there was all kinds of
layers to that and red i loved red you
know my old man smoked cigars and
windows rolled up driving to the dump
every saturday so i was used to it i
enjoyed being around that and and he was
uh he was wise and everybody hated him
and he hated new york do you want to
know why he hated new york rich why is
that
because he grew up there but
he felt that the nit screwed his george
washington team out of the nit
appearance in 1937 and he never forgave
that he said they just didn't want a
little school from washington to come in
and beat their st john's and all my ass
you know and he he never forgot it and
he couldn't get past his hatred of all
things new york even though you know he
was a brooklyn guy of course dan
shaughnessy here on the rich eisen show
before i let you go let's talk about the
here and now does this look like 2001
all over again for the patriots what do
you think you know it's not bad rich and
i know you had a great day there went to
the game i heard all about it here and
good for you guys
it's
you don't want to say mac jones to tom
brady it's ridiculous we know that but
at this stage
he is i mean he's doing what tom did at
this stage which was game management you
know short passing game he's accurate
and he doesn't he doesn't choke in there
he takes hits he's taking too many hits
frankly and bill i guarantee you bill is
enjoying this year
probably more than any year since then
more than 18-0 more than that stuff
because this is hard and they've rebuilt
it the defense is great they're
ferocious and the offense they get by
and he's just beaten the pants off these
other coaches and it's a big advantage
every week we don't know where it's
going to end but as you know the
conference is not super strong this year
and they've kind of got the why not us
attitude here right in the 2001 was you
know the only thing that's different is
that there's not some 100 million dollar
contracted quarterback that that had
already taken the franchise to the super
bowl that's there i guess cam was that
role in a way right but but he got cut
so it was max gigg from the start
outside of all that we are all and many
people are just like well how far can
this team really go with this kid anyway
and in 2001
even john madden said that when the game
was on the line that they should play
for overtime in the super bowl like even
to the very end nobody believed it until
brady brady didn't believe it he had his
hands on his head in that famous
photograph on the podium like
why not this year is a repeat for real
it's it's there i mean i think they're a
team nobody wants to play right now i
think the colts of that team right now
and the chiefs look like they got it
going but
i'll tell you i mean tennessee is coming
in here this weekend they're eight and
two that's going to be tremendous it's a
one o'clock game i'm surprised they kept
it there and we can't wait for that one
because uh they have a tough they have
buffalo twice in the colts after that so
i mean you know it's getting harder for
them what's the vrabel belichick
relationship do you think well rich
that's a good question because he's not
afraid of him like all these other guys
who wet their pants and look across the
sideline and you don't have that you
know rabel's got he knows what they're
up to when they beat them in the
playoffs in 19 brady's last game
raibl was pulling some of that rule book
stuff that bill likes to do oh go read
the rule book and you know bill was out
of tearing his hair out because rabel
did it to him so yeah i mean he was a
wise ass when he played here you know
you think of him because of the position
he played and the size of him he's not
going to be a you know big acumen guy no
he he was they all knew he was smart and
he he gave crap back to bill even when
he was a player and now he's he's loving
this and i mean hell he could be coach
of the year if they don't stop losing to
bad teams dan shaughnessy here on the
rich eisen show and i guess uh
tying in your book to uh the topic du
jour in the nba where lebron's suspended
for a game isaiah stewart one game more
than lebron because of the reaction to
getting hit
um you know what what
i mean you're talking about old school
basketball in your book you're laughing
already i think you know where i'm going
with this it's like
what what was your sense of wow
that was unfortunate the kid's reaction
when he was bleeding and he was just
he's out of his mind i mean that's
unfortunate you know that league did
what it had to do but i know i talked to
mikhail you know just about how the 85
86 team translate to today's game
because they went 51 at home they had
five hall of famers and could they play
today and he's like yes because they had
seven feet people and they had
long-range shooters and and it and rick
carlisle who played on the team and
coaches league today says it translates
and but kevin said if if we played by
today's rules you know and the way
they're calling it we'd all foul out in
the first quarter so that would be a
problem and one last thing on that
none of this hugging the guys on the
other team afterwards or or you know
assembling let's look where are we going
to play next year let's get together and
create our own team larry bird hated
bill lambert so much
that at the all-star annually larry
would be named a starter of course his
first instinct was to come to us in the
lowly media and say you have to let me
know when those reserves are announced
because i hate when bill lambert makes
that team because it ruins all-star
weekend for me because i got to get on
the bus at practice on saturday and
bill's sitting in that front seat and
saying good morning larry and i got to
say screw you bill
[Laughter]
that's a real story huh i mean
that's the fact i mean there was
literally he hated him that much huh he
literally hated him ruined his all-star
weekend to have a teammate bill lambert
i don't blame him i hated lamb beer too
like even even watching the wnba
playoffs this year i'm seriously easy to
do i'm serious like i like we're
watching it at home and i point to my
kids i'm like you see that coach you see
that gray-haired man i almost used the a
word you know
but i had to
honestly to this day i can't even watch
land of the lost remake you know repeats
knowing that he was a sleaze stack as a
high schooler i hate the show now even
with him
you know what else larry hated about him
his lambeau's dad was a fortune 500 guy
he was the only player in the league who
didn't make more money than his father
great stories dan thanks for the call
happy thanksgiving to you and yours
congrats on your book i appreciate it
thanks richard you got it you got it
same to you and your family that's dan
shaughnessy right here on the rich eisen
show wish it lasted forever is where all
books are sold hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here